okay I literally have no idea who you
are what you're talking about okay
anyway I don't it's not about who I am
you had had all the Time in the World to
join Logics live you know I didn't want
to name drop or nothing but you decided
to join oh anxious oh anxious oh that oh
anxious Avery's live yeah no no thank
you
ay yes yes absolutely I don't I I don't
eat dog food okay so the criteria just
to be clear if any person claims to give
eternal life that if there's a text if
there's a text if I bring you a text of
suon individual CLA and this text claims
that this individual gave eternal life
that is is sufficient to worship that
person is that what you're saying well
well what they're saying is is that that
is a sufficient claim to where they are
claiming to be God now whether that
person I guess they can't speak for
themselves well well I'm speaking so
whether they are God that's that's
another another discuss who am I
speaking to who am I speaking you're
speaking you're speaking to Avery you're
speaking to Avery you're nightmare so
right right so speaking to the host or
am I speaking to
what's we're all one we're all one so
yeah I can imagine that yeah good good
good that's right so so would you so
would you agree that if someone is
claiming to give eternal life that they
are claiming to be God so Avery very
simple very simple I've spoken enough
with you you you've had enough of my
attention I've given more attention to
people much lower much much more less
we're just waiting on an answer oh no so
very simple we're just we're just
waiting on an answer let's see if we get
an answer so now just to be clear host I
asked the host no problem no problem I
asked the host and I asked
the you ever seen the mem brother you
ever seen the meme hold on brother hold
on brother you ever seen the meme where
this the African dude and he says you're
the I'm the captain now logic's the
captain
now okay so just to be clear you don't
know the criteria for to distinguish God
just to be clear so just to be clear are
are are you are you gonna answer the
question my brother and stop wasting
time so just to be clear just to be
clear I have no problem conceding just
for the sake of argument good there's an
obscur can I can I can I can I please
speak so I have no problem conceding for
the sake of argument that there are a
lot of erroneous obscure irrelevant
texts that deify many things there are
texts out there that deify monkeys I can
find texts that say certain monkeys how
to say are God cool I'll tell you what
I'll help you I'll help you the New
Testament calls Jesus God ah very good
very good so
so don't don't say no one denies it
because you guys all deny it except you
you're new you're different every every
don't get
jump we're happy we're happy that you're
actually here telling theth take it easy
take it easy take it easy we're happy
that you're here telling the truth
you're already in panic mode you can be
quiet and happy you can be quiet you're
already in panic mode just like he was
the other day of course I was just to be
clear just to be clear so just to be
clear brother okay so why is it as I'm
why is it as I'm addressing the topic
I'm being I'm being interrupted and then
when I'm quiet you guys call me brother
brother it's called a conversation
brother so interrup interruped brother
ham being
interruped yeah come on okay so I'm
confused stop crying bro so this is this
is about the third time you guys have
brought up someone outside the
conversation while we're discussing the
we we're we're having a conversation
right now stop crying let's actually get
into it let me finish what I was saying
let me said you said the New Testament
call
God you can't interrupt me if just go
ahead and land bro you're waffling land
I would have been done about five
minutes ago no you would not have you've
been crying this entire time just land
your PL
good okay so very simple nobody Den
please let me finish speaking nobody
denies the New Testament calls Jesus God
what people deny just this is irrelevant
to the topic but what people deny is
whether Jesus Christ himself in the New
Testament called him God I agree John
1:1 the Gospel of John calls Jesus God
cool great that's no one I don't know
anyone who denies that and I'll tell you
what any if anyone denies that I'll I'll
happily correct them because the New
Testament calls Jesus God but whether
Jesus Christ the man you worship himself
calls himself God in the New Testament
that's something I would dispute that's
something other
people that but that now so so just to
be clear what I'm saying is not a new
position I know you're desperate for
cheap points but that's not a new
position I'm not done I'm not no dude
that's enough monologue then that's
enough monologue that's enough monologue
you diverted the topic I had this we
weed on the topic Ry if I can't finish
speaking if I can't finish speaking I'm
I have no reason rsy look 30 SEC 30 more
seconds bro land your plane cuz you're
just going on and on and on L of respect
L respect You Don't Own Me yes I do I
own you here I own you okay well why why
are you talking to me then why you talk
if you're not going to let me finish
speaking if you're not going to let me
finish speaking land your playe bro
what's wrong with you I'm going give you
one more minute brother I'm going to
give you one more minute time to land
your plane brother one more minute okay
brother yeah good so wait wait let me
time this let me time this hold on let
me get this I don't even need a minute I
don't even need a minute you're going to
get a minute brother you're going to get
a minute brother cuz I don't
want go ahead brother you got a
minute okay good so very simple long
story short that was a diversion Avery
made so I had to address it so if you
don't like me diverting the topic then
don't complain very simple regardless of
what the New Testament says about Jesus
whether it calls him God doesn't call
him God whether Jesus himself I'll tell
you what even for the sake of argument
if Jesus himself s called himself God in
the New Testament easy Avery get get
your inhaler no problem get your inhaler
very simple whether or not the New
Testament calls him God is irrelevant
the question is what criteria is there
to distinguish creation from Creator
showing me a text that calls Jesus God
irrelevant I'm asking what is the
criteria to distinguish creation from
God there you go that's it okay thank
you so much for finally Landing you just
repeated yourself over and over again so
what what we can wrap up from what you
said Ramsey is is that hey what's up
Marlin is that what up what up is that
you uh you acknowledge that the New
Testament calls Jesus God correct but
you but which is beautiful and that you
said you would correct you would happily
correct anyone that says that the New
Testament does not say that Jesus is God
so I'm going to be holding you to that
I'm actually just be hitting you up a
lot be I'mma be telling you I'm be like
hey I'mma call ramsy Muslim because
Ramsey said that the New Testament says
Jesus Is God you better not do that
Rumsey gonna get you you know I'm I'm
I'm hold you the topic you going to
address the topic well well well I I'm
I'm addressing everything you said so
I'mma hold you to that secondly you said
you said that Jesus himself doesn't
claim that he's God so this is why this
was relevant because we when they asked
you about giving eternal life and you
wouldn't answer that I asked you
specifically I did if somebody claims
that they give eternal life no you did
not but here it is again and please just
give a simple answer it's a it's a it's
a yes or no or just answer in the
affirmative or the negative please yeah
if someone claims that they are the one
who gives eternal life are they claiming
to be God yes or no
Ramsey okay so the question I asked
earlier was let me excuse me Avery calm
down I know it hurts I know it sucks
just calm down it does suck to listen to
waffle
with no syrup I didn't bring the syrup
today I know it hurts take it easy dude
take it easy I bring I didn't bring I
didn't bring the syrup I know it hurts I
know you can bring Sam here if you want
to help tell baby you to be quiet I I
didn't bring the syrup here for your
waffles no problem no problem no problem
very simple bring Sam when you was
running from Sam who had time to join
the live earlier like come on stop
taking everybody let's allow Avery and
uh yeah so very simple very simple by
the way just to be clear I wasn't
planning on being here for very long so
I can't stay here for long
there's yeah pleaseing calm down calm he
already giving us the
out calm down calm down calm down oh man
when you're not on the Muslim platform
they got to go quick man they always
gotta leave quickly we're not allow ti
so T So Avery I don't usually spend very
long in Tik Tok lives I have a life
that's a lie you all the time I haven't
been live in weeks what you talking
about you usually wait until I get you
usually wait until I leave the live to
come up on the live stream Muslim
platforms oh you never get on and then
he just stays on for hours trust me I
don't watch this kid I'm just going to
be I can speak yeah so look Ramsey
here's the question again hopefully you
can answer if someone claims that they
are the one who gives eternal life could
are they claiming to be God yes or no
ramsy okay so the question that was
asked of me earlier was very excuse me
the question I asked earlier was what
criteria do you have to distinguish
creation from Creator the host has a
topic up there it says Jesus Is God he's
making the claim they told you giving
eternal life Avery ay calm down no I'm
helping you out they told you giving
eternal life can you respond now a Avery
I'm Not Jesus I don't need help from
you well you sound like Allah you sound
like Allah because Allah needs your help
chap 47 verse chapter 47:7 Allah says
you help him he'll help you you scratch
Allah's back he'll scratch your back
chap
why have you forsaken me why your Allah
needs help your Allah needs help why
have you foren you sound just like Allah
so now answer the question so now let me
finish speaking let me I give you the
big screen I don't know how to I don't
know how to do that you need
to you just take pict fine okay put it
this way put it this way if you
interrupt me again I'm going to leave
I'm say go and cry off and just run off
okay no problem simple as that so very
simple very simple the question that was
be quiet the question or excuse me the
topic of the of the what Call of the
live is very simple Jesus Is God so I
came up and asked a clarifying question
what is the criteria to distinguish
creation from Creator and now you're
telling me hey there is a text somewhere
that says that g that that calls Jesus
God great okay cool I don't care the
topic is what is or the question I ask
excuse me what is the criteria to
distinguish creation from Creator I
don't care Avery I don't a flying you
know what about what any text that
mentions Jesus that supposedly calls him
God I'll Grant it to you for the sake of
argument Jesus Jesus calls himself god
of the New Testament I'll grant that for
the sake of argument that is irrelevant
to the topic and I know you know that
Avery and I know you desperately want to
avoid that because you don't have a
criteria to distinguish creation from
Creator you are dependent on the New
Testament calling him that so now the
question that I asked that was ignored
so I'm going to ignore your question
what is the criteria to distinguish
creation from Creator don't divert don't
do a Christian Shuffle on me answer the
question and if you keep ignoring my
question and if you keep interrupting me
I'm going to leave you mean nothing we
know you're looking for a way
out well I am leaving actually my house
so I am going off actually yeah so so so
Ramsey we we know you're looking for an
excuse to run away but Ramsey you're
answer got your your question got
answered by the by the brothers and the
sisters here they gave you one of the
criterias that separates God from
creation they said giving eternal life
but you Deni that that's when I then ask
you if someone claims to give eternal
life are they claiming to be God and you
continue to refuse to answer the
question I don't need a twom minute
monologue I don't need a two-minute
monologue so yeah just to be clear I'm
get I'm I'm I'm gonna help I'm gonna
help you just like you Allah needs help
I'm giving you the answer again one one
of the
go on a second pipe down pipe down one
of the things that separates God from
his creation is that he's The Giver of
eternal life do you agree with that
ramsy yes or no okay somewhere there's a
text somewhere some obscure text that
says Jesus gave eternal life so in other
words hold on let me adjust theck let me
adjust
the I'm talking to the host I'm
sorry did I bring up did I hey JP brt I
know you're afraid Avery I know it hurts
JP did I mention a text don't be afraid
Don't Be Afraid like the god you worship
I just asked a question huh I didn't
even bring up a text Avery Avery don't
be afraid so we're just waiting for him
to answer the question let's see don't
be afraid Avery don't be afraid I know
it hurts I know it sucks do you that one
of the things that separates God from
his creation that distinguishes
him gives eternal life yes stop begging
like the god you worship begged stop
begging be quiet stop you can keep
begging me you can keep begging me keep
begging he's a was he's a waste of time
man no problem no problem so just to be
clear if I'm was clear
you I'm GNA give him the last chance to
see if he actually answers let's see
let's see okay good so very simple I
already granted for maybe the fourth
time let's say the New Testament alls
Jesus God that's fine let's see if he
answers in 10 seconds Excuse excuse me a
I know it hurts I know it sucks I know
it hurts Avery it took about a day and a
half for your God to die do you agree
that only God gives eternal life yes or
no beautiful very simple he said
beautiful let's see if he answers
beautiful okay since you desperately
want to appeal to what the New Testament
says Fine Jesus says in the New
Testament I do nothing of my own accord
I only do what God tells do what God
tells me what God gives me the power to
do get out here
okay there you go see look at that see
desperate desperate byebye goodbye go go
find Aisha's
dolls bro I was about to call Hamza bro
tell this call Hamza would have put him
in his place man again wasn't put on a
cross naked and claimed to be God clown
go go worship shes kab but guys guys pay
attention to this notice how we appealed
to what he was asking we appealed to try
to substantiate a criteria something
that we can all agree on and he was a
afraid to acknowledge it he was afraid
to get into it he said oh you're
avoiding the question you're avoiding
the topic I'm addressing exactly what
you said my dog we were live for five
hours ladies and gentlemen he knew it
Usman knew it Muslim Lantern knew it we
were live for five hours and none of
these dudes showed up I'm here right now
pressed him on on the question that he
asked and he couldn't answer a single a
single question Subhan Yeshua
stop manifesting brother slow down I got
that c if you want he's a Christian he's
a Christian oh my fault Amir my bad I
got it clipped if you want that